[Music]
phil collins
shot to the top of the charts in the 80s
with classics such as
in the air tonight and you can't hurry
love
his star waned in the 90s though but
nearly 40 years on he's now more popular
than ever
after these two stumbled across his
music
last year youtubers fred and tim
williams
listened to phil collins in the air
tonight for the first time
their reaction went viral viewed nearly
10 million
times ain't gonna laugh
man ain't never seen nobody drop a b
three minutes in a song
academics say the singer's fame and
influence has shown an
n-shaped trajectory rising sharply
before falling out of favor
and then becoming cool again and have
called it the phil collins effect
he sold cds cassettes and records but in
the next decade he became the epitome of
uncool
but as new generations start listening
to his music
he's made a bit of a comeback record
shops say
they've seen a resurgence of acts from
the 80s and 90s for these kids
everything's new so you don't have to
just look at this week's this month's
this year's releases you can go back and
imagine imagine the joy of discovering
those bands for the first time i mean
imagine people hearing fluid mac for the
first time
the beatles like that must be such an
exciting experience
i wanted to test the theory out for
myself
[Music]
well he's the voice of disney cadbury
gorilla that was all i remember
shiman freeman powell sky news